c'est ce que l'on appelle une expérience
singulière partir une journée à
l'aventuré ramener des images avec son
portable
cette petite équipe se prend vite au jeu
dès la traversée
une traversée en bateau barbecue une
originalité qui donne le ton de cette
formation
[Musique]
les coordinatrices des madonia des
élèves on veut des images table les
valeurs de plans vous les respectez le
maximum des plans d'ensemble dans leur
ferme oiseaux donc ceux qui s'occupent
de la fon essayer d'attraper un maximum
de choses la flore en bas âge vous
laisserait libre et tout et d'abord dans
l'observation du milieu certaines
espèces attire le regard
il ya des nids d'oiseaux dugommier rouge
des cactus des petits crabes adou sébou
cette maîtrise d'un mouvement qui te
penches légèrement pour avoir douté
malgré tout le monde vers le ciel est
très bien c'est enrichissant
c'est la première fois que je fais ça et
ses avants fabrice et 7,6 alors d'espoir
je trouve ça cool autant de curiosité
qu'il faut savoir mettre en image et
c'est loin d'être simple
les conseils de la compagnie sont donc
précieux soleil dans les yeux donc faire
attention parce que tu 1,3061 déjà il va
mettre du temps à s'acclimater et
surtout il faudrait essayer de se mettre
de façon à ce qu'ils soient a dans le
viseur de la caméra
les stages et un font des erreurs
valérie rectifie le tir
logiquement il faut mettre comme ça pour
climat choix bien on va de la première
sinon de mettre le téléphone comme ça et
de filmer en fait un peu en mode photo
parce qu'en fait c'est très difficile
après d'adapter sa dans nos montage à
nous en tout cas bon caïcos et parfois
c'est surtout au montage que ça que ça
se remarque ex arast prompt à rames yeux
et à mieux faire et à corriger en fait
pourquoi faire un petit film avec un
portable
le projet s'inscrit dans une démarche de
valorisation des outils modernes mais
pas seulement
le téléphone portable hamon
à mon avis rentrer dans les habitudes
mais n'est pas nécessairement utilisées
pour toujours des choses intéressantes
on a toujours cherché justement à
valoriser le pays les valeurs la culture
en fait ce que les ce qui nous échappent
le plus souvent quand on ne regarde pas
autour de soi et ça reste dans la même
dynamique
l'expérience s'est poursuivie dans l'eau
dans un cadre idyllique pour ne pas
oublier cette journée particulière